goodbye my dear dear friend and brother
you leave behind a colossal wake a
profound chasm that can never be filled
dove Cameron emotionally speaks out for
the first time about her descendants
co-star Cameron voices death sharing
this tearful tribute in the form of six
black-and-white Instagram videos saying
goodbye to her friend the actress also
revealed why she hadn't spoke out sooner
admitting she felt weird talking about
Cameron's death on social media
I felt really emotional an intimate and
social media is the opposite of God but
decided to to bring everyone in mourning
together the only way to get through
right now is to like I think we all need
to just if we want to be expressive
Cameron died on Sunday at 20 years old
what was special about Cameron was who
he was in the small moments when maybe
no one was looking a rep on behalf of
Cameron's family confirmed the news to
ET explaining that the actor died of a
seizure in his sleep Saturday night
which was a result of an ongoing medical
condition which he was being treated for
Cameron was known for starring in
several Disney Channel projects
including at Jessie I think we just got
discovered I knew I was good but I
didn't know I was sausage good
and his role in The Descendants
franchise as Carlos the son of Cruella
De Vil oh don't you ever miss screaming
at people and just making them run away
from you you're thinking of my mother
and I was usually on the other end of
that so not really know if he spoke with
Cameron in 2017 weeks before the second
Descendants film debuted the first one
was really big and when we first heard
about you know we're doing the sequel we
were like all right how are we gonna top
the first one but I think we did I think
that everything is bigger the sets the
the choreography the numbers all of it
is a really high energy and high stakes
and stuff like that so it's pretty it's
pretty fun
[Music]